yes no and welcome to this video this is
a rather spontaneous decision because I
try to record a rapid game but I have
upped the level of opposition to 2200
because some of the games were a bit
one-sided him musically and I didn't get
an opponent for two minutes or so and
now I saw that on the hourly bullet
arena is coming and I decided to simply
join this tournament and make a bullet
video I mean I don't don't think I've
done one of those for ages and they're
probably extremely rusty I don't play
bullet at all at the moment I've played
my fair share in former times but not so
much
and recently I'm what don't even know if
the salmon is adjusted correctly by full
so that between can see the tournament
properly 1 0 ok this is a dog I had
looks kind of ok ok so this is not
really one of my usual openings but it's
bullet you know ok I felt I should
should fire somehow play quickly and
that that at least was kind of
successful doesn't look all that great
nicely doesn't threaten the bishop
really good hard to keep it on C 694
looks a little bit annoying he's got a
high rating this guy I don't know my
Buddhist rating is it's not I haven't
played it all look at it so I'm trying
to say
so it's hard to tell what it means
I'm not awful in bullet I'm just rusty
doesn't have squares for the rook no
okay
and there's this doubling here right
that I can do that what it's called the
circle but I don't don't think I want to
do that simply because I'm I'm not X not
so quick I think after this this pause
okay 700 maybe I can dissolve what I
don't know I'm just going to play normal
stuff I mean normal stuff is the wrong
way to phrase it like a normal speed so
to same I'm just a night drunk they're
getting trapped I'm winning this piece
nice the night is a little bit of sad
though I need to put it on B 3 C 5 is an
extremely nice square for it now
threatening g5 you can renew this threat
nerville quite a number of good things
that I can do it's easy to play with the
piece up and the much better version d7
coming
I should be should be a checkmate
somewhere haven't spotted yet I know a
Spider Queen d8 milk coming okay so
decent start here with two wins I don't
intend to do bullet videos regularly it
was just like I wanted to move to make a
video I've got like time to do so and I
couldn't get the we get the other video
on the road I don't quite remember how
this works is line it's very strange
do I threaten I threaten discoveries but
he has screen sex maybe it's very tricky
Queen a success may be the easiest move
he's allowing this this is probably high
okay so this was the idea where is this
going to one something okay but the
queen is not really well placed and this
is a Ted Lane but I didn't like my
position and I'm I'm so what I won't I
I know I'm a little bit there the rook
has played has some squares now I wanted
to say it doesn't have that many squares
but it actually has some squares 98
major group g8 mate was an idea funny
one but I don't don't really see a way
forward here besides the time play can
try to play with the f5 f6 or something
but he can take yeah one on time but it
was a bit of a strange game lucky weird
oh is that a set a chance to buzzer I
think I can try one berserk and fry this
of course extremely shaky and I could
have taken I just got to check out this
check cream III would have been a tad
better okay so that worked it was it was
a scary one though it was a somewhat
scarier game okay so Bishop g5 coming in
what is going on here 26 Queen f3 does
he have a good discover check I don't
see it it doesn't have a good discover
guy can actually play Queen f3 on Queen
c6 grab everything chick doesn't really
in that much so let's just play this
ending slide too much I've got a jeep on
this available ok so I am getting much
more gain Sun than the other guys it's
not a super strong field I guess still I
wasn't quite sure what to expect because
of my very limited unit practice at the
moment so I'm getting a Benoni here with
the Templar it's still relatively decent
for miles not sure about the Bishop g5
setup in this in this scenario if this
is any good
not happy about this move kind of thing
you play and then you instantly if I
think okay was that really good good a
very weak to instruction it's annoying
really high five I have blundered a five
actually I can take here should you can
take this I wait
check oh I didn't see this check coming
Wow
that is going to be tough shake to check
without only six I mean there is a bit
imprecise the screen is hanging half it
was one hope here it was a shaky to say
the least
shaky shaky shaky
so she's I
good choice in bullet cannot make this
muscle quickly I kind of don't mind
exposition in general it's kind of a
k-means is six no but this is going to
be dangerous with Knight f6 on the cards
okay
96 that's me
okay now I get here to take it probably
yeah don't know so play play simple
chess as the motto of this game get try
to get two slightly more comfortable
position it's rather dry but this
doesn't mean I cannot win it the bishop
is slightly slightly problematic a g5
that that's not helping them this Bishop
is getting worse so we should trade one
roof then this Knight comes to f5 I
guess very little that you can do can
you 795 is going okay I can go before
should form the airport okay we will
slowly surly make progress in this
position
Oh actually I just really matter it's
not that bad actually could have checked
them it was might be better but it's
pretty terrible anyway from like yeah
and he's running out of moves they're
also sold back to tournament why doesn't
that work now now I'm back to the
tournament I'm still only 12 points
ahead I don't know if this is a if only
is the right word or this is already a
lot this is the number two place here so
before fine playing on the nights of six
premium funny funny funny
I said rocking I don't don't really
think it works it is messy though that
that's for sure this one yeah ok so I'm
returning this piece can take on d5 how
disguise I mean that that doesn't work I
mean in general with it is dangerous I
see why sir as far as points and it's
just like firing away not caring much
about anything yeah
and this is this is not easier not
now he ate not good not good not good
what are you doing I foiled a good move
this also is good what did he do to me
in this game that's really really
strange just playing completely reckless
but killing me me okay Wow don't talk
about objectivity but it's for staking
Shoeless quite clearly okay so why don't
you multiply that sometimes you play
stuff and you wonder why you did it
this is one of those cases I was just
making moves and didn't really pay much
attention to what I was playing Oh mmm
but I have I can try to keep this piece
I don't know if I can manage rupee money
problem I think no I can't take this now
I would like to get this this this Becky
guy again
we smashed me in this game I still am
number two in the tournament
just cancelled I guess if success the
chick coming isn't that dangerous
it looks dangerous
I need to open this up Bishop h4 s
hanging over I will go G for to open
this up as quickly as possible f5 is
hanging well it's the Queen let's say
Queen on g7 go join his spy checks come
on
no not making a draw
okay so I'm eight points ahead of the
number two can I get them again but
please note canceling this is tough to
play okay maybe trading wasn't exactly
the most testing way right there it's a
very good positional you can let's do
this
it's a bit it's a bit flashy but just
come before ok so we decided to wait
yeah ready for 94 on this night again
over to a5 just a subject slightly down
on time the position is good
instead checkmate that I can not play
for I would like to meet here simply to
win quicker here it is critical that the
foil mmm okay still 12
points
six minutes but he had a good one here
eating me in the process a new car like
a [ __ ] but I do not get Americans
served no 36 place this is a good
observing opportunity I'm super slow as
is the problem like me berserk in
summary slow
such longest ending position is very
good
this is takes time by 95 I'm winning of
many parts here oh shoot i blundered the
freeing piece layer oh my god
had to gamble i had absolutely no time
and I didn't know if he goes up or down
yeah I shouldn't I shouldn't deserve him
ready should and just not quick enough
so ii listened to too much okay so four
minutes left in this tournament why do I
play the fringe reason oh okay this is
fine it's a little bit strange but I
don't mind this position now I can go to
f5 always it's really quite a past
okay all right this is not bad I think
it's kind of okay wow it's a really
drastic measure why was that necessary
don't think it was really now it's tough
for him to defend his his material I'm
just going to take everything yeah with
like my yeah doesn't score so I'm not
going to lose the first place yeah I
guess and Galit lesson lesson don't
don't don't the circum I'm Gilovich
pretty high rated lousy doing it cheater
for me not really a cheetah it's a big
pawn 95 I probably does it anyway age
six was a silly move at least in a
bulldog game it was quite silly because
people would on 95 and just say I do
this kind of a kind of just just fire
mm-hmm didn't pay any attention c-4 had
an idea
[Music]
so check there it's probably lost good
what can you do still has to win it come
on and what does make me Akane its mate
actually a that was very silly game
losing against this [ __ ] is a little
bit frustrating wait doesn't go get all
of course but it's good HS ok so I can
go on one more oh okay it's probably
about the end of the world
you can still play this pollution no but
it's not so bad
looks like a fairly normal Petrov I know
he is weakened himself quite a bit not
sure that that was necessary to do
shaken deform
but that was a bit silly this should be
five didn't really do much king after to
answer it's suicidal let's play the
ending my time isn't good positions okay
we should be five I didn't pay didn't
really see coming
that's a bad clean bus well by the end
of this term is really not got iam I
played pretty badly the last couple of
games only badly Wow really running out
of steam iam and what happened now you
turn I still wanted even though I played
pretty terribly at the end using at the
end a couple of points and thus far was
okay but then I kind of had a party with
them well I don't play it all that often
those tournaments it must been a really
long while yeah I hope you enjoyed it it
was a bit of a different thing posted on
this channel
um and I now try to get a rapid game
again thanks for watching